my name is Alison Lucas ii and i am a
fifth-year architecture major here at
Carnegie Mellon University and I was
originally born in Manhattan and now
live in a small town Mullica Hill New
Jersey my speeches title is catalyst for
change and it is because I believe at
Carnegie Mellon we are the catalyst for
change we are the thinker's leaders and
innovators of the future so this time
last year I was studying abroad in
Prague in the Czech Republic and really
fell in love with the people and culture
and the architecture of the place and so
my senior thesis is focusing on an
existing communist bunker that has been
derelict since the fall of the Berlin
Wall and my project is really interested
in engaging three distinct user groups
that currently do not interact and that
is the tourists that come and flood the
city of Prague the residents that are
still grappling with their past and what
they can do to move forward into the
future and the european union officials
which are in the city for the year as
the czech republic is the president of
the european union currently so I'm
fitting program into this existing
bunker that includes everything from
recreational facilities to community
centers to conference centres for the EU
officials as well as tourist amenities
and it has a lot of historical social
political implications because of the
nature of the site and it was the site
of the velvet revolution in 1989 and the
sight of what was once the world's
tallest statue of Stalin which is now
gone but they're my project also
includes a memorial for that as users of
a place we experienced things in very
different ways based on our previous
notions and our our place in the world
and so my thought is that architecture
really allows you to explore the self
through an experience and the thing is
with these three different groups of
people for the residents
their history dates back so far in time
that they remember this place as
something that has been very politically
charged and it has a very different
meaning for them than the people who are
coming to the site to get a view of the
city to get that picture postcard photo
so I think that that interaction between
people is something that is really
powerful but that the architecture there
can really help mediate that meaning and
that experience between the people and
this summer I hope to prepare a
Fulbright scholarship application to
continue my work on this thesis and
hopefully actually realize this project